[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's time for another
conversation with an interesting person
from the internet and this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we have the
one and only Michael Stephens creator of
one of the most fascinating channels on
the internet you've heard of it
Vsauce he schools us on who he is the
person behind the science is he just the
Internet's version of Bill Nye or
something more we also talked about his
surprising path to where he's at with
Vsauce now and the unexpected way he
came up with the name Vsauce his initial
viral success had nothing to do with
science so this is convolution happening
here we also discussed the secrets to
how he gets so many views on his videos
does being a Google employee give him an
unfair advantage as a youtuber no I got
to admit when I talk to someone like
Michael Stevens who is obviously a smart
gentleman he has reputation for being a
smart guy I selfishly like to be able to
say oh yeah yeah you know I was an
engineer once I majored in civilization
I have an engineering degree I have an
industrial engineering the career right
and so you know that's your background
I took three the levels of calculus
right and so we you know this if you've
listened to us talk about our
backgrounds before that you know we have
engineering degrees and we did that for
a few years now the interesting thing is
that we have pretty much done stuff
together since we met one another right
school first grade on we kind of okay
friends let's kind of have listen we're
doing stuff together
except for this a graduate on college
now getting engineering now
interestingly we were doing the same
thing I mean we both got engineering
degrees and we both wore khakis and
polos to work every day yeah we went to
two separate places did you tuck your
polo in oh of course
you you could not tuck your polo in I
think on an occasional Friday
I wouldn't tuck my polo but then you
just look like a punk you mean you were
you wore
khakis with an untucked polo that
doesn't even look good looks kind of
sluggish yeah it's like I'm not gonna
trust that guy with any calculations
yeah you know on well on Fridays well in
Fridays I wore jeans but untucked a polo
into them I mean it was casual Fridays
we can't get too casual you're not gonna
wear flip-flops or something but the
thing that's interesting is that I know
a fair amount about your time at IBM as
an industrial engineer simply through
stories that you've told now that we do
this but you we didn't talk about it at
all at the time I I had no idea what you
were doing on a daily basis what was I
do I mean what was I supposed to say hey
man I got to tell you about this
conveyor belt layout that I designed
today when the when the refurbished
computers come down here I figured out
the best way to put them in a box and to
take the box I actually bought the
machine that tapes the box it's amazing
will you come to work with me and see
the automatic box taper that I purchase
if you had to talk about it like that I
would have shown up oh yeah man and
these guys who work back there they're
from Africa and they're really they're
awesome guys and we're friends and they
tape the boxes that's that's how it
worked well but isn't it faster than
machine tape isn't it fascinating that
you know now we know too much about each
other and I mean we're with each other
all the time so I mean it's just that
the our daily routine what would you
have told me that's what I would have
told you I would have said well what I
did today is I went on the internet and
I just looked at ultralight planes and
how they fly around and I looked at some
blogs about ultra lights and then my
boss came over you procrastinated and he
had incredibly horrible breath that he
would put his he would put his face up
over the top I'm not cubical and talk he
wouldn't come into my cubicle he would
just put his head over the top but
really so just see his face and he would
be like seven to nine feet from my face
but I would smell his breath it was like
a projectile
Alecto so it was like right into my
nostrils and so much so that I had to
alter my breathing my managers breath
stunk really bad too and
he had a we had offices we didn't have
cubicles but so you wouldn't tell me
anything about the actual job you did
did you actually do work yeah yeah well
but it's because in the specific sector
of the engineering world that I was in
the energy market at the time with the
whole this is kind of boring information
but long story short with the Enron
scandal it drastically impacted the
workload at a firm that was designing
power plants so much so that for the
whole last year that I worked there we
did nothing except like read novels and
go on the internet because there was no
jobs because it was all job based there
was nothing you could do that I told you
they wanted you to be reading manuals
and like learning standards but no one
did that especially somebody like me who
knew I wasn't gonna do this forever what
were you supposed to be doing there
designing how thick a pipe should be
they don't raise water anyway well now
how thick but how big around so the
first year ok the first few set that one
straight no but how much you know how
thick a pipe is is the wall thickness
and how the diameter of a pipe is what I
would determine so the material in the
diameter and how large the retention
pond should be so this is actually kind
of fascinating if you look at a power
plant the entire the grade meaning the
slope of the ground when you look at a
power plant it's all graded to one side
or to a number of sides and there's a
retention pond basically it's like okay
we put these huge slabs of concrete out
here on earth and now we have to take
into account that we have changed the
characteristics of this particular place
so that when it rains we've got to take
that into account and we've got to
funnel all this water that comes off of
these places put them in a pond and then
distribute them you know into the you
know off of basically Dam them up so
they don't ruin anything so there was an
ecological consequence to what was
happening you had to account for that by
creating a retention pond didn't built
in like designing drains and then pipes
that would route the water to the pond
and that sounds awesome
I built ponds but you couldn't even put
fish in them I was always like let's put
some catfish out there how come the last
thing that we don't do is turn this into
a fishing pond and everyone just looked
at me like because that's not what this
is about bro
makes me want to go back and do it now
that you got me all fired up about it
let's design some ponds ma'am you can
but you can tape the boxes and I'll
design the ponds let's do it
no thanks okay I'm pretty grateful and
even more so right now after this
conversation of what I'm currently doing
yeah this is pretty great and now you
know why I never told you about that
yeah because I'm I'm kind of sleepy now
but give me this one concession here
everyday no once a week on Fridays we
need to start wearing khakis and tucked
in polos because I think that it's like
professional the opposite of casual
Friday the rest of the world is enjoying
casual Friday dressing like we're
dressed right now you have
straight-laced Fri straitlaced Friday
and everybody here at the studio comes
in dressed business casual and we we
just be thankful that we have this
slacker job basically you know we get to
talk to each other every day you know
it's not a slacker job well it's a fun
it's a fun job is we yeah it's not just
like a job but it's fun job whistle
blows whoo I'm shifting gears now do you
want to say about that I was gonna shift
back to Michael tucked in polos and get
into this thing because who else gets to
talk to someone like Michael Stevens
about his personal life
nobody but us right no one else is doing
this I don't think well that's not true
but it's nice that you think that but we
did have a conversation with Michael
about his personal life and also
everything that led up to is amazing
success on YouTube which is six million
subscribers on his Vsauce channel with
titles of four videos including why are
bad words bad is anything real how much
money is there on earth what if everyone
on earth jumped at once now let's talk
to the man behind these irresistible
clickable titles here it is our air
biscuit with Michael Stevens
[Music]
and then already gone through an energy
drink you're going about to go through a
coffee and then we've got to back up why
no but how come you have two waters or
three of us well I already got one if
I'm betting that we all aren't gonna
need a full bottle an additional yeah
we're gonna share one bottle we're gonna
pass we're gonna pass it you know I
shared a water bottle with him in real
winkler once really yeah bonds yeah I
went to this film school at in orange at
Chapman University for like two weeks
over the summer I came and spoke and he
left his water bottle on the lectern and
afterwards I was like free Fonz spit so
I took it and drink it no I wouldn't
dare you know do that and taint the the
saliva but I don't have it I don't know
I might so it was icy when you said that
you're like I shared a water bottle with
Henry Winkler I was like oh that means
you guys were hanging no tennis together
he doesn't want no water he doesn't know
that I took it and I thought you know if
I ever drank out of this it would be a
little bit like kissing him
yeah when what did you think about that
like and so then you drank out of it or
they didn't I was afraid to do that so I
just kind of I probably honestly threw
it away but just kept telling the story
right right because it's really about
the story we really about that we once
shared a lobby with Henry Winkler
remember that yeah he was in the lobby
and so were we that's pretty much it
yeah shared it though yeah they were
sharing it really good I remember as a
kid being a pro wrestling fan and
thinking I don't know why I thought this
because I never saw Pro Wrestling in
person but I was thinking if I were to
ever be at a pro wrestling event and
Hulk Hogan were to run past me and give
me five because he would do that as he
was going down into the wrestling ring I
was I developed a plan that I was going
to come home put my hand in plastic and
try to capture some of the sweat from
Hulk Hogan miss and even though I never
was able to execute the plan it was a
fully foreign plan in my mind right
but you would eventually wash the hand
you would just bag up some of the
molecules that were still there right
and then I would keep the bag and then
wash my hand that's great that's
actually really clever why I'm pretty
clever but it wouldn't work I'm just
like trying to bag a fart or something
no it's you never tried to bag a fart
why are we always going to head for it's
the three of us and last time you hear
on the mythical show we talked in detail
about diary and if you like like most of
that got cut I'm thinking it's for like
the you know anniversary special deleted
scenes bonus but but let me let me put
it to you this way you're breathing in
atoms that whole Cogan has breathed in
you don't need to bag up a high five
molecule that's just a point just be
just be yourself in theory though but
you can't you can't point to it yeah
this is him you want to create
memorabilia that's why you at least kept
the water bottle for a few minutes or
days or weeks or whatever it might still
be in my closet in my bedroom at home in
Kansas but is it true though that means
statistically speaking have we breathed
the same molecules as Hulk Hogan like oh
yeah
many times over ain't many times over
atoms are just so tiny they're so tiny
each breath contains quintillions of
atoms and so just to get a hundred of
them from hulk hogan's breath it's
statistically very very likely that
you're doing it right now my goodness
this is amazing we're breathing Hulk
Hogan's air and you know what there's a
100% chance that we have breathe Ric
Flair's air because we shared an
elevator with him remember that well
that was greg the hammer' valentine it
wasn't a flare they were both at the
same hotel in Knoxville Tennessee
you wrote you you and Tommy Rutledge
rode the elevator with greg the hammer'
valentine I rode the elevator with the
Nature Boy
that's called a bad choice on my part I
mean and I'm breathing elevator I
breathe deeply when I was saying that
when I was in that elevator with the
Nature Boy you're talking about
wrestling to it
I'm sorry okay sorry junior Pro
Wrestling know what I think I was I was
born at a different time I was a bit too
young during during the whole Cogan era
and then the Stone Cold Steve Austin era
I was
in my like science phase I wanted to
know a bunch of facts and own test tubes
and so well there's a lot of physics and
progress there there really is and
there's a lot of acting which I was
always interested in as well really yeah
I did theater all the time
all through high school college and in a
way now I still perform right to a
global audience well let's do that let's
go let's go back let's go even earlier
so where you from Stillwell Kansas still
well Kansas Stillwell is that's a small
town I've never heard of it it's a
pretty small town not named after the
stillness of its wells but rather a guy
named mr. Stillwell who helped get the
railroad through the city or something
and by city I mean it was a small town
as Overland Park Kansas has grown it has
become a bit bigger but it's still not
really a suburb there aren't sewers
there aren't curbs there aren't leash
laws for dogs but every day there are
traffic lights um oh yeah there are a
few traffic lights okay yeah I was born
in Kansas City Missouri hmm and then as
soon as I turned you know five years old
start going to school my parents moved
to a house that wasn't right on this big
busy road Ward Parkway and we moved to
Stilwell Kansas which it's a bit
political right because all my family
lived in Missouri and here we are being
kanzen people that was there's
controversy there
yeah because we'll be traitors to the
state of Missouri yes I think so
by leaving by leaving we only lived a
mile from the border I could just ride
my bike over to Missouri and we would do
that we go to Belton Missouri to buy
fireworks every year okay oh so they got
loose laws over there on the fire yeah
yeah yeah South Carolina we would go to
South Carolina right yeah right across
the border all the firework tents would
set up there over the summer yeah yeah
so that was the thing oh I'm riding my
bike across the border that was that was
kind of like an adventure for you as a
kid yeah and it was exciting because
it's also a nerdy thing borders to be
like wow like I can have one foot in
Missouri and one in Kansas and it's
completely an arbitrary thing there
humans made up right but you're like wow
there's something special about this
it's like sitting on the equator we used
to do that with the counties we would be
like this is the Johnson County Johnston
County line was it John Johnson County
Johnson County yeah counties were a big
deal back in North Carolina Johnson
County that's where Stillwell is Johnson
County versus ya know this Johnson guy
did a lot of counting Wow I was was
Johnston so guy's a jerk
yeah yeah yeah so did you grow up with
both your parents what was your family
situation like yeah definitely a group
with both of my parents and a sister two
years younger than me named Melissa okay
and she is just so athletic
she played semi-professional American
football on all girls team what yeah
Jesus just bought it yeah Wow she just
bought a dirt bike and I'm like oh cool
but now she's doing like BMX tournaments
on it and I'm like you gotta be kidding
me I break a sweat just peeling an
orange but my sister she is so fit and
athletic and she does all kinds of
sports so what I mean so what is that
like growing up you know where you kind
of you've got the stereotypes backwards
a little bit in your family you know
you've got the jock sister and you're
into science yeah so there were still
stereotypes though still like well if
you're going to excel at soccer then I'm
gonna excel at knowing the most about
everything else yeah my my older
stepsister anything she liked I decided
not to like just because she liked it
like music as a kid I decided not to
like music use it all Pyarelal period
because Amy liked music you could have
just picked the genres that she liked
and hated those I was that I was that
determined to to be different I'm going
to swear off all the Arts because you're
a fan of music right so did you
consciously say this to people oh I
don't like music yeah that's when a kid
would say yeah it was like yeah that's
her thing yeah
but but then I slowly got into it I mean
I got like weird al' yankovic tapes
which you know you can argue that's not
really music so I was like okay this is
like a comedy thing something like this
is this is making fun of music just like
I do all the time so have you heard this
experiment has not been done before but
you have a child step one and then you
raise your child only listening to Weird
Al Yankovic so that when they go off on
their own as as you know an adult and
they hear all of these songs the
originals they think who are these
people ripping off Weird Al and not
being funny that's well that's a cruel
experiment yes sir I'm still fertile I
could I can still do it
are you still fertile yeah I think so
yeah Congrats all right let's keep going
here so your your sister a little bit
younger what was it like growing up in
that environment or did your parents do
what do they do it was a fantastic
environment my mother right now is
working as a para at a high school and
she's a crossing call what a para a para
so she helps all the teachers and she
helps with students that need extra help
follows them around and gets to be in
school all day in high school but then
also gets all the high school breaks so
she's off for the holidays in the summer
and so just perfect because that makes
it easy for my sister I had to come home
and visit and not have to like have her
take time off work and blah blah blah
my dad is a chemical engineer and he
worked for a company called Black &
Veatch the whole time really uh I know
someone who worked for Black & Veatch
really my first job out of college was
Black & Veatch it's ret no kidding and
we're in Kansas City Missouri yeah they
are to always talk about Kansas City
like we're gonna send you to Kansas City
whoa okay so go on what did you do for
them I was a civil engineer civil
engineer yep yeah I I course it's a you
know a power design firm you know so we
in our office in Cary we designed mostly
natural gas plants and so I was not just
civil but specifically what you know a
hydraulic engineer so yeah I would
design the waste basically the water
retention system that is drainage system
funny and then like route some of the
piping and stuff did that so excited to
it sounds very exciting it was riveting
my uncle's still
works for Black & Veatch well I'm sure I
know a lot of people who know your uncle
because we had like a hundred people in
our office still it's still there in
Cary North Carolina and they they went
to and fro from Kansas City all the time
well your uncle still works there your
dad doesn't anymore but he did work
there when you were growing up as a
chemical engineer yeah and he worked in
sulfur recovery so when you are getting
natural gas petroleum out of the ground
there's a lot of sulphur in there more
than you need and a lot of these these
plants that process or extract petroleum
products are really far away and so it's
not like I'll throw the sulfur in the
back of Ted's pickup and we'll drive it
to the you know place where they make
fertilizers or paints or what whoever
needs the sulfur it's usually in the
middle of Siberia or something and so my
father invented a process called step
sulfur to energy process that actually
took all that sulfur and then you could
in some way use it to actually get
energy back to keep running the plant
was very popular he has a patent on it
oh wow maybe event.this while I was a
child so is this like I mean is this the
kind of thing you invent this and it's
like a life transformation kind of
situation well he invented it while
working at Black & Veatch so they owned
and okay owned it and then I don't know
exactly all of the details but after I
went off to college
he got a offer from a company based in
Malaysia to start a sulphur recovery
group for them so he went off made his
own company called KPS and I wondered
why did you call it KPS why didn't you
call it David Stephens awesome company
or something yeah and he and he gave me
this advice he was like Michael I don't
want to meet a client and tell them hi
I'm from David Stevens energy recovery
I'm David Stevens because then it seems
like that's it you know if you're right
David Stevens from KPS well right what
is KPS that sounds huge mm-hmm yeah we
digitized your rhettandlink ink yeah
it's like the yeah I'm gonna read from
Rhett linking I mean I have to do this
all the time when we're like set you
know setting up you know a new phone
account or something like that
because we do all this ourselves so I
said like what's the company I'm like
rhett and Link Inc and they're like in
your name from like Rhett right Laughlin
it gets kind of small kind of quick yeah
they're like okay I see what kind of
coordination dad is a smart guy any
lever yeah now so for you as a kid were
you a very inquisitive child kind of
nerdy were you you you know how would
you describe yourself then and where
you'd like take taking after your dad
genetically or just socially or what was
going on I took after my dad genetically
because that's the law of biology that
also got a great question also I took
after him after my detention well I
wasn't adopted in my mind it was it made
it was a more intriguing question he
took me to museums a lot he's a very
inquisitive guy very interested in all
kinds of things from philosophy to music
to Chemical Engineering to physics to
history to art and I call him a polymath
which is what I would like to consider
myself as well I don't know how you
qualify to be a polymath but what does
that mean exactly polymath it's someone
who is interested in and can have
meaningful conversations about all kinds
of disciplines did you invent that term
no not at all no it's been around since
the word poly and math have been around
oh yeah I when I think of math I think I
like arithmetic right but I think math
in this sense can mean discipline okay
like Jared Diamond okay that guy is a
polymath he's like oh you want to talk
about chemistry and also the
Anthropology of tribes in New Guinea I
can do that
so it's a nice way to say no at all yeah
you want to be a you want to be a
palatable know-it-all which that yeah
that to make it a compliment cuz no it
always look good to call it not a
know-it-all but an interested in it all
okay
okay and and that's that's that was my
identity you know how in high school
you've got the the Goths and the jocks
and and whatever well I wanted to be the
kid who
had read the encyclopedia that's a joke
right oh that guy's so nerdy he read the
encyclopedia well I did you did I did I
read the Encyclopedia not because well
it was interesting sure but I also just
really wanted to be able to tell people
oh yeah well I read the encyclopedia and
okay so it's okay that's honest I
appreciate that
early on you could tell that I was
curious but also was a performer okay so
you didn't necessarily have some of the
other stereotypical things aspects that
come along with someone who's really
interested in science and math and all
these other things at that age which
might be social awkwardness etc really
good question I see I wasn't that
socially awkward because I was such a
class clown right I was not super
attractive I didn't I wasn't in the
popular crowd but I did on two occasions
get invited to their parties because of
my attitude in class mm-hmm right I
could be sarcastic and talk back and the
kids loved it and the teachers didn't
mm-hmm so I got suspended my sophomore
year in high school yeah
suspended what did you do exactly
alright let's go back and just explain
that this particular class I was a
really bad but great class clown in
right I would get the kids to all laugh
at things and I would you know criticize
the assignments in funny ways and the
teacher really didn't like that so then
one day I was going to make this joke
about my friend who was quite nerdy he
tucked in his okay he wore his gym shirt
to class yeah kind of a no-no kind of a
weird thing but he was gym class it's
not gym class it was an English class
and he not only wore it to class but
tucked it in with the belt hmm it was
like okay you're not fooling anyone
that's it that's our gym shirt like it
even get out of smells so a few days
later I wore my gym shirt to that class
and everyone's like oh Michael like
he'll do anything and I said wait I need
to tuck it in uh-huh
but I was a little bit of a chubster so
I had to unbutton
my pants to start tucking this thing at
all that's a no-no everything goes
according to plan
sit back down doing the assignment so so
everyone's in class this is like in the
middle of class hold on guys
I need to tuck in my shirt that's part
of this journey to open my pants to all
of you but everybody got it oh yeah
because Ralphie he came in yes yeah
because this other student had done it
they all got it and didn't think a thing
of it but was his name Ralphie uh almost
let's call him Ralphie okay his identity
he seems like a Ralphie to me and so the
teacher realized this could be the last
straw mm-hmm let's call this sexual
harassment taking you know ants off in
class so she won't mean did you pull
your pants down like a toddler no no I
just I unbuttoned and probably unzipped
a little bit just so I could get my hand
in there to tuck the shirt you you
weren't like a toddler using the
bathroom you were like an old man
tucking in his shirt exactly do this
type of thing of public all the time
this morning yeah I don't do that in
public anymore but the assistant
principal shows up and takes me out and
as far as he knows I just tore my pants
completely off and did a striptease but
cousin because the teacher used the term
sexual harassment right so they snatch
he snatched you out of class yes there's
the principal and so then I was stuck in
what's called ISS in-school suspension
I've read that defended a yeah right and
I wasn't able to explain to anybody what
had really happened
I didn't even speak with the real
principal but I told the assistant
principal look what happened is like I
had been trying to get up to the cookie
jar to steal a cookie which is bad and
then as I do it oh whoops I trip and my
pants fall off and now I'm in trouble
for that but that part was an accident
mm-hmm whatever the principal never
heard my explanation and so I was
suspended for three days Wow yeah and I
had to go to all my teachers and tell
them that I was suspended for acting up
in class and if it
up to them to give me any assignments I
would miss so that I could do them while
I was suspended or they could just say
no you deserve this and I'd get zeros on
this thing so that was kind of like a
walk of shame and you go to all my
classes before my parents came and got
me and I was in a lot of trouble and
that kind of thing ends up being on your
record essentially right and we asked
you to start trying to get into college
yep
so when I applied to colleges fill out
all the information and there's that
great question it's just one question
with a yes or no checkbox have you ever
been convicted of a felony or suspended
slap it together they're together and if
you check yes you have to submit an
explanation that you wrote separately
and you find yourself talking to
colleges about your fly being open right
it was a kid your rap hands me my button
he came to class with his gym shirt on
yeah and they would hear that and go
okay I I believe you weren't trying to
harass anybody but that's just not even
funny like that's not even a very clever
trick you tucked in a gym shirt at least
get suspended for a good joke but here's
here's what happens so I turned it
around
and it wound up making my college
applications stand out because I was
gone for three days
I was a little heavy at the time as I
explained needing to like do this whole
like pants thing because I couldn't get
a shirt in otherwise and that summer I
mowed yards and ran and lifted weights
every other day and I lost like 40 or 50
pounds whoa okay I got really tan I mean
I was hot all right I was hot and I came
back that next year and the attention
led to a physical transformation exactly
huh and and beyond that I did a bunch of
community service that summer working at
this Nature Park which was cool because
everyone else there was my age and they
were doing court-ordered community
service so they were there because they
you know broke stuff vandalized stole
things were caught with drugs whatever
but I was just the kid who was like I
really want to get community service
hours and sure enough when I got back to
school I was hot I became I think vice
president of National Honor Society so
on those college I which is what happens
when you get hot
that's what happens when we get hot yeah
on my applications it all says yes I got
suspended but it was a wake-up call a
clarion call to change that caused me to
better myself and now I'm ready for you
University nice yeah yeah when I was
doing community service at the Nature
Park this one kid that I really liked
hung out with a lot he was there because
he'd stole a canoe from a sporting goods
store that's tough like how do you do
that he's like it made so much sense if
I tried to steal something small I get
caught but if I just walk out of there
with a whole canoe people will think
well he clearly knows what he's doing no
one's just gonna walk out with a canoe
but the problem was his pants were
unbuttoned and I think the problem was
sexually harassing that canoe yeah yeah
if only the problem in his case was that
he was like 14 and 14 year olds don't
just like buy canoes and drag them out
if you've been like a man if you were
not a or a woman just an adult person
here general or if he was wearing like a
you know bright construction vest it
would look like oh it's official like
just let him do it yeah so he was there
at the at the yeah and what's neat is
because I was the only person there who
wasn't in trouble through juvenile court
I was given the most responsibility I
got to drive the golf carts around with
all the plants and mulch or whatever I
got to kind of lead the projects yeah
yeah so dad as you can see I hit my
nadir and then I could only go up from
there and you did yeah that's what got
you into college where did you get into
cod University of Chicago and it it was
a result of this like the essay that you
attached the sexual harassment
explanation I think it helped a lot yeah
Wow and you wanted to or what did you
studied what I studied neuro psychology
and English literature mm-hmm okay so
and you mentioned that you started
getting into theater and performance and
stuff so that started a little bit
earlier but you carried that into
college yeah so in high school I started
doing exactly what I do now on Vsauce
which is I wrote informative speeches
for a program called forensics that's
like a
a club at your high school exactly and
then on the weekends you would go to
different high schools and you would
perform informative speeches about seven
and nine minutes long to judges and then
they would you know at school all public
speaking not debate it was not debate it
was competitive public speech okay right
and there are different events you could
also do oration which is a speech that's
a bit longer and it's more about an
opinion letting people know about
something or giving them information
well it's different than informative and
I did both and I did my first
informative speech about ketchup and as
a guy who had grown up reading the
encyclopedia and I could come up with a
lot of things to say about ketchup or
tangentially involved in ketchup and I
was quite excited about these things I
mean I've talked the same way I do now
my first tournament I got first place I
was this fresh matchup for ketchup I
called it ketchup on ketchup oh yeah I
get it yeah play on words play on words
now let me tell you this in high school
I went through puberty at like eight
years old not even high school so I was
you had you had a beard really when did
you get the beard is every time ah yeah
I think I was still in the womb when the
beer was coming in it was sprouting yeah
so before all the other guys caught up I
was like quite you know mature looking
and big and I was the only guy in my
high school who could play adult male
characters in plays huh so they hear
that I'm doing speeches
I don't really act but the drama teacher
asked me to audition for Repertory
Theater and I just gave one of my
speeches and they were I think they just
said look we need this guy cuz he looks
so old mhm and sure enough I performed
in a lot of plays as the dad or the
oldest man right I make sense because
you'd rather use one of the students as
opposed to like the janitors I mean
sometimes they use the janitor sometimes
they use just a - somebody who works
unemployed dad right and then it's like
that's a little creepy this adult guy
right yeah so I could do it and I
already had like this kind of receding
hairline and that was so lucky I mean if
there's any piece of advice
that it's okay to kind of have a gimmick
because you'll get in faster I didn't
have to necessarily already know how to
act and a lot about theater I just was
able to say yeah sure I'll be the dad
I'll be the old male figure and that's
what I did
but the other people that I acted with
the other kids were so much more
talented than I was that was that was
amazing
because they were so good I had to keep
up with them and I had to learn and I
always felt like I was surrounded by
people more talented than myself and
that's that can make you scared but it
could also be really inspiring and so I
think my life has been a story of trying
to find those moments where I can be the
one in the room who knows the least and
is the least experienced and can
hopefully get some of the surrounding
colleagues talent to rub off on me
so what where was your mind when you
went off to college and had that double
major and this this bent towards
entertainment I knew I was never going
to be that great of an actor but I got
really into the theory of theater and
directing
so William ball and Bogart I read
everything they wrote yes so connect the
dots for us and how it went from where
you were at in college to where you're
at now so I'm doing a lot of theater
right especially directing that's what I
love to do and then I saw a video
probably on college humor or something I
don't think YouTube was quite there yet
and it was a mash-up that took the
shining and made it look like a funny
movie okay laziness yeah it was a um
movie trailer that for a movie called
shining which is this feel-good
relationship thing behind the Sun and
like a family vacay he just the the guy
who edited it just chose the right
moments to make it look like a family
fun thing and then he put music in that
really pulled at your heartstrings yeah
and it floored me that was so powerful
too
day we take it as you know well anyone
can do that but at the time this was
like a landmark thing that you could
take a piece of work like The Shining
and make it mean something completely
different without even needing to own a
camera it was just straight up editing
and that was huge to me so I immediately
joined our campus film group so that I
could learn how to use editing software
and one of the first things I edited was
Ferris Bueller's Day Off the trailer
remixed to look like a horror film okay
so you did the opposite I did the
opposite shiny and what I did it was so
simple but it was a great exercise I
just took the entire movie Ferris
Bueller's Day Off and then I took the
trailer for Friday the 13th with Don
LaFontaine voice over and I used his
voiceover as the template and I just
found Ferris Bueller scenes to fit each
thing that he said so when he goes 13 of
her friends are dead I took the nurse
giving a hug to Sloan right yeah and it
just it was really easy you just find a
thing that kind of matched and then
you'd put it in this like spooky music
to him and yeah and then where did you
post that I posted it on about 16
different video sites everything from
Ebaum's world to I film - Yahoo - yeah
CollegeHumor yeah we were there same
strategy I we we used to have an account
everywhere all those places you just
mentioned and many more and it was it
was um called super distribution Funny
or Die was one yeah and did it take off
anywhere yeah on CollegeHumor right so
they put it on the front page if you
want you today you're gonna go this is
really a clumsy edit but seriously at
that time we're talking about 2006 2005
this was like whoa you just changed a
piece of culture and and how many people
have watched it two million
that's insane so that made me really
excited i remixed george w bush and karl
rove into a rap video which again is
terrible I called it Bush and Rove thug
life so in their own words they were
like talking over
a rap beat kind of thing there was no
auto-tune back no there was well maybe
there was some sort of auto-tune thing
but I was no opportunist right
I just remixed a couple of songs make it
rain by Fat Joe and ass one other song
and I just found moments like George
Bush raising his hand up and then I
looped it so it looked like he was going
yeah to the beat I mean now I can't see
what I'm doing but it's very hip hop oh
really in tune with dance moves and
that's what I did and that wound up on
the front page of Funny or Die with a
review by Chris Hinchey Brooke Shields
husband and he was like I judge
someone's friendship with me based on
the reaction to this video yeah and I
got like a hundred thousand views by
being on the front page of Funny or Die
beyond 2006 and that was giant and the
fact that this celebrity talked about it
I'm like okay I know what I'm doing this
is incredible it's basically art but
it's also comedy and look how big the
audience is and it was just editing just
a little bit of editing that you learned
by going to this club it wasn't creating
anything from scratch it was basically
using that footage ya found footage
template and so did you start to branch
out at that point or just more the same
so then I made a YouTube channel called
campaign 2008 but the pain was spelled
Pai in like ouch pain did it very clever
and I just liked ketchup ketchup on
ketchup so there I did all my political
remixes I think Bush and Rove thug life
might be on that channel and then I just
started making an edit for every person
running for the presidency in 2008 huh
so I did one with Ron Paul that mixed
him up with some Chamillionaire song um
yeah gosh I kind of him forgetting some
of these I did a Hillary Clinton one
where I found a speech where she said
something about white something like red
white and blue and she also talked about
like power and so I made it look like
just talking about white power yeah it's
really stupid stuff but sensational
sensational yeah but really they were
exercises that allowed me to learn how
to use editing tools so if I saw an
interview with Ron Paul with a blue bag
I'm like I think I can chroma key that
blew out and put him in a Chamillionaire
video and sure enough I learned how to
do that and it took hours because I was
having to like Google how to use chroma
key on Final Cut and write stuff you
were doing this totally alone I was
alone yeah in the basement of the like
Biological Laboratory which had a media
suite and that's what I would do you
know I didn't even have my own computer
that could run final cuts so I would get
up really early and go there and just
work you know yeah look at that guy
doing biology in there yeah did your
very night did your friends at the time
know that you were kind of creating
these viral videos or was it because
typically people who are in college we
were creating viral videos it's more of
a collaborative thing oh my friends get
together we thought this would be funny
I found an interesting that it seems
like an interesting isolated experience
it was very isolated yeah because I was
working with found footage just editing
on my own and I at the time I worked in
the basement of the big library just
opening mail that they received and
sorting all the mail and so I would just
sit there and I would listen to
political speeches and then take notes
about ooh the way she said the word but
was so isolated there I could easily
make like cut that out and make it sound
like she talked about her you know a
bottom but right and I would just do
this and while I opened and sorted the
mail and I think because all of my
friends in college were older than me by
the time I was a senior they'd all
graduated and and my closest friend who
was my same age he was studying abroad
that year so and I moved into an
apartment that was a studio so I lived
by myself and so it was a very isolated
life I think my girlfriend had broken up
with me too so all I did was watch
political news take notes on the
speeches and then go to the library at 7
a.m. when it opened it closed at about
1:00 a.m. and all I did well so were you
sad or were you happy no I was super
happy I mean I still had a bunch of
friends through theater that I hung out
with during the day and I'm still going
to classes but I'd be calm
incredibly focused on each project
mm-hmm and it was interesting because
then the project itself was faceless so
exactly yeah you know it was kind of it
was this channel that it wasn't
personality based right right so the
most famous episode I ever made through
campaign 2008 was called Hillary Clinton
farts and I found a moment in a debate
where she cleared her throat and I could
put in just a little and I made it
really subtle and I put a filter on it
so it really did I mean it looks
realistic and in fact it's fooled a lot
of people uh-huh and when I when I told
this story to some people didn't put it
to a beat you did no this was just a 28
second long clip and I watched the whole
thing and I made notes of all the other
brock obama john edward is that the
interviewer and audience members
reactions and i got all the right
reactions where they just sort of put
their heads down or they just kind of
walked every blankly and then the very
last reaction is this big guy in the
audience who's just looking nodding his
head like no that's my kind of girl
and that was 28 seconds long it took off
like crazy i think it has something like
9 million views and then a guy just
ripped it off of my channel because it
was faceless and put it on his and that
one has like 12 million views oh really
yeah and he cut I did put a campaign
2008 logo at the end that I'd made but
he cut that off or you know we just got
this was he got ripped everywhere and
you can find it in all kinds of video
sites when I guess at the time I mean it
he's like a lot of us back in that time
2007-2008 you know you didn't really had
there was no vision there was no
business plan associated with this was
just like this is really cool and people
are watching and exactly doing you kind
of get addicted to yeah you know that
the attention that these things garner
yeah yeah I made one called Barack Obama
would where I made it look like Barack
Obama was singing a Bollywood song I
just I took one of his speeches and I
cut out every vowel and consonant sound
so that then I could take the Bollywood
vocal track and just say okay that's
like an it's a long a let me get the
Barack long a mouth shape and I animated
him singing it and that like
lip-synching lip-synching
exactly and that wound up on around up
being written about in Newsweek magazine
Wow yeah and I didn't even know who I
was and I didn't ask they just said you
know here's a still frame from brocco
bhalo would a crazy video made by an
Obama fan which how did they what didn't
say I was an Obama fan I was just a guy
editing a goofy thing but it got in
Newsweek and that was insane so at about
that time we move on to the next part of
the story which is Ben rellis
discovering the videos that I was making
in Chicago and asking me to make some
kinds of edits for barely political
which at a time was Ben was the creator
of radio yeah yeah and that was huge
that was like when that came out people
were like wait Obama must have funded
this no one just does this on their own
a parody video had never really been
made like that ever so to this day Obama
girl is in textbooks because the 2008
election was this like first election
social media was around for and he's a
big deal so so and then creator of Obama
girl this this amazing viral sensation
contacts you because he's seeing that
you're doing something political same
thing right political comedy yeah yeah
and so I made a piece for them that I
was paid some flat fee for and it was it
was the same as Hillary farts but it was
John McCain this time and I got him
calling up on a phone laughing and I
made it sound he was burping and then I
found footage of Hillary Clinton
answering a phone and kind of like she's
confused about the thing and so he just
keeps farting and burping over the phone
and then she's like what I what and then
and then he just like laughs and hangs
up and at the end how did that window
man I think it has like three or four
million Wow yeah but it was on political
channel at DEP yeah yeah it so did that
transition into a job yeah so so then I
started doing a lot of editing for the
stuff that Mark Douglas and rusty Ward
were writing for barely political and
they would like overnight me the footage
and I'd edit the thing then when I
graduated it kind of turned into I would
to work with you guys all the time and
they were in New York right they were in
New York City so by about September we'd
worked out a deal and I was hired
full-time by next new networks which I
owned barely political and I moved out
to New York City and did that for like
four years right and there's a number of
things that are fascinating about this
for me I mean I I think when I first saw
you because we've all witnessed you know
the explosive growth of your videos over
the past year or so especially and like
we're talking a five million subscriber
job in like a year time yeah yeah and I
think the thing that you know when you
see something that becomes incredibly
successful on YouTube as youtubers
watching that you conjecture and you try
to figure out why it's working and you
make assumptions about things and I just
was thinking okay this guy obviously is
from a science background he's
incredibly smart and he was some
professor somewhere some scientists
somewhere that got somebody was like hey
we know we know how to produce this
content and we're gonna put you here and
make you do this and it's just working
great yeah that's just my the assumption
that I brought but it makes so much more
sense to hear the story which is
obviously you're a smart guy who read
the Encyclopedia who can speak on these
subjects with authority but the reason
that it's so successful is because you
lived it you discovered how things work
on the Internet personally and
personally produce these things in a way
that you just can't pull some professor
out of a college and say hey talk about
this you know I think it's fascinating
even going back to what your you know
your you know oration and how you you
speak and how it all doing because the
background from that - yeah I think a
lot of people don't know that backstory
you know they think maybe that I'm just
brought in and there's a whole team
producing them but up until a month ago
I was doing all the editing and
everything I researched and wrote and
then I shoot alone just like say Frank
you know what the camera has to be close
enough to my face that I can reach out
and press the record button and focus it
yeah to this day I still shoot alone
luckily I have an editor now who can
help me get that and he can work on the
edit while I work on the next step
or on other projects but yeah I grew up
with the Internet
I grew up ever since maybe 2005 I think
they've only been a few occasions I
haven't made a video during a week since
then but some of them were faceless they
were just crazy edits or compilations
that didn't say hey I'm Michael Stevens
now at some point next new networks that
you worked for became was bought by
Google or something happened there and
kind of at this kind of at the same time
with so many changes going on with how
YouTube itself worked there was a lot of
Vsauce on the homepage of YouTube I
remember there was there's a meeting
amongst a whole bunch of youtubers where
YouTube people came in and explained all
the changes and at one point there was a
an outrage where it was like why is this
Vsauce can get on the homepage all the
time but I can anymore what's happening
and then there's somebody saying well
you know Michael is a Google employee
and it's like oh that's the answer and
of course I don't believe that's the
answer but you know you wrack your brain
and so is that really what it is do we
need to become Google employees to
really well then explain first this
thing the acquisition so that you're
technically working for Google of course
yes so first of all no I mean I wish I
knew how to get onto the front page that
is a super-secret thing that is always
changing right which is kind of cool in
fact I wish I knew more about how these
algorithms are built because there's not
anyone who makes a conscious decision to
curate anything onto the front page
because that's that's not a very you to
be thing right it should be this is what
people are watching and you can actually
surface super cool content faster using
mathematical algorithms so they'll
detect wait a second Perez Hilton and
Sports Illustrated both embedded this
video
that's a weird combo clearly this is
something important get it up there it's
important right or it's being viewed by
a very diverse group of demographics get
it up there right but the specifics of
how all these things are weighted is a
super huge mystery I think to almost
everybody but you're a Google employee
right
so to go to the acquisition next new
networks had created a lot of really
great shows and we discovered a lot of
great talent for instance the Gregory
Brothers and auto-tune the news mmm been
rellis found Michael Gregory doing his
little funny things and and we started
collaborating with barely political and
an auto-tune the news and so YouTube's
wound up acquiring next new networks so
that we could take what we'd learned in
the field making all of this stuff and
and send it out to partners at scale
right and teach them what we had learned
and give them advice and all of that and
by the way Ben rellis is the reason why
the mythical show existed you know
working on the innovation side of
YouTube from within YouTube's and what
does YouTube wants to invest in well one
of those things is long-form I was
having a relationship with Ben that
that's where the mythical show came from
just as a side note so he got moved over
next new networks got moved over and you
as a part of that as at Google I'm yeah
and it was it was just it was phenomenal
because all of a sudden YouTube acquired
a company of people that had been using
YouTube and Ebaum's and Yahoo and every
possible way to super distribute Netflix
Roku boxes
all of these things we've been using
this for years and we'd been building
successes and failures and we tried
everything so all of a sudden we brought
in all these people to youtube who had
been using the system for their well
being you know if I didn't get enough
views on something well I might just get
fired right there was this pressure to
always be innovating and to be figuring
out secrets like oh if I do this I think
I might be able to get more views or I
might get onto this chart or I might
edit all these things and how do I use
annotations to do something that's
really tricky and gets me blogged about
like that was our whole mindset it was a
really creative environment so then
YouTube got all of this knowledge when
they acquired next new networks and now
I work for YouTube as a programming
strategist spreading out my successes
and failures and questions and
challenges to other Creators letting
them know hey I did this once you know
two years ago and it worked really well
or I did this and people hated it so
maybe don't do that and how did how did
the whole moon
to London factory so I was a programming
strategist in New York City and they
needed someone to do that same job in
amia which is Europe Middle East and
Africa I was going out to London for a
week or two at a time to sort of meet
with their partner managers and tell
them you know hey these are some cool
things people are doing there's some
really innovative things people are
doing these are some programming
strategies that are working shows that
don't just get people to click but get
people to subscribe right and I wound up
loving the team out there in the UK and
all of Europe and Middle East and Africa
and then I said hey you're hiring
someone to do what I do in New York can
I apply for that and they said sure and
I got that job and was lucky enough to
get to move to the UK and it's it's been
amazing I don't think it's a coincidence
Vsauce has grown as fast as it has since
I moved out to Europe and really learned
a lot more about the world and about
global audiences well let me ask you
this I mean are you are you studying
not only your audience but these things
these other things that are really
popping on YouTube are you a student of
those type of things in order seeing
where V sauce should go and what are
those what are your thoughts on that
yeah where V sauce should go in my
opinion is beyond YouTube you know
YouTube is a is a part of a business
right and it's it can be a really
powerful part of a business but I think
that V sauce has a lot of exciting
opportunities offline that will help us
let the rest of the world know that we
exist who isn't looking at YouTube as
closely and let them know that there's
such great content on YouTube if that
means like writing columns for a
magazine if that means getting a vsauce
board game i mean hello like those kinds
of things are really what's exciting to
me right now
but it's it's all a google entity now
right or is vsauce separate is it owned
by Google - or yeah it is it is and so
part of innovating and part of like
figuring out what advice we can give to
channels means that we need to run
Vsauce like it's a channel and so if
there are opportunities and other media
if there are any way we can hell
bring more people to YouTube that is
what we're looking for
well I got to say that you know the
content is very welcome on YouTube from
my perspective because you know I love
the fact that there the people are
responding to content that is
challenging that is informative that
isn't tricking people into watching
videos that isn't just about videogames
and isn't just about the latest
celebrity gossip I mean I to me that's
you know a lot of people have their
opinions about what YouTube videos
should be and what the YouTube audience
is and I think that the fact that your
videos have gotten so popular the test
of the fact that there's people who
actually want to learn legitimate
information and apparently it's a very
broad audience and that's I mean that's
encouraging yeah yeah the audience is
really broad but youtube is so big
there's room for everything do you make
3 hour-long films perfect YouTube's
great for that do you want to just watch
videos of the surgery you're about to
have yeah YouTube has that too right so
it's easy to think that there's only one
type of genre or style or click that is
YouTube but YouTube is gigantic does
your brain every turn ever turn off you
just like veg out yeah for sure
no I think I think you know as I kind of
get a life back like I said you know I'm
taking a vacation of sorts starting
Saturday and I like to hang out with
people who just don't even do YouTube so
how are you getting a life back yeah are
you that implies that a I did your life
was taken away yeah or you didn't have
one yeah and so tell us is is that true
and then how you go about getting it
back what do you mean get your like that
look you know if you want to create 13
minute long episodes every week and
build an audience and get 5 million
subscribers in a year you know and you
also want to have a life at the same
time you don't don't you know now gonna
call and gray from CGP grey put it
really well he's like okay look you have
four things in life and you get to pick
two job friends family and health pick
two
I've been focusing on my job and my job
as the two things you doubled down
doubled down and that meant that
everything I did even watching family
guy episodes at 2:00 in the morning was
all about huh
what if dogs talked okay that's could be
an idea and then I'll read about
anthropomorphism all you think me no but
now I'm starting to realize you know
taking a break it's like really good for
your mental health for your creativity
and spending time with someone who does
a completely different job and not
thinking about the sauce or thinking
about any any you know other project I'm
working on and just being a human and
learning and hanging out with different
people invigorates you so you're
quitting for a while know that what
you're saying no not at all not at all
I'll still make an episode so it's not
really a vacation but it's it's just
rather than spending 24 hours a day
researching and writing I should spend
like 21 really what you're gonna that's
your plan that's my plan for a relaxing
vacation just to taper it a little bit
yeah and it's also important to meet
people who do different things because
it'll blow your mind right and that's
why when we say Vsauce is a scientific
Channel I think not really I mean I do
well what's the shortest poem you can
write what's the greatest honor you know
a lot of these things are more about
language and culture and the arts and
history and it's not just laboratory
experiments and test tubes well listen
man thanks for coming here to the round
table of dim light ooh yeah now you need
to sign and you can cite it in English
yeah I would love to I only know English
you'll say un poco espanol
[Music]
[Music]
and that's it our conversation with
Michael from Vsauce he's not Vsauce and
we would always refer to him as Vsauce
but uh but he says Vsauce Michael here
but he's saying Vsauce is the audience
and it's just the thing and then Michael
is him here I wasn't confused by that
when he was here in the room so I knew
his name was Michael and I appreciated
kind of getting to know him as a person
I found it very fascinating you know
timing is everything I think we've
learned that from a lot of these stories
we've heard with the advent of the
internet and YouTube and internet a
manure three parallel tracks his
scientific mindedness and fascination
with all those things which become the
content of Vsauce his class clown
madness and wanting to be an entertainer
speech Giver
actor and then the third thing in
college of just wanting to be an editor
and making viral videos that really had
nothing to do with the other two and
then the three of them come together
because his success is Vsauce and
because of YouTube you know yeah we
definitely can relate to that and how
these weird skills and you know desire
for something to happen and then the
opportunity that YouTube provides leads
to a career it's just it's nuts but I
did find it very interesting he said
that his friend said there are only four
things I think was his friend well
somebody told him there's four things
you can have in life there's four things
in life but you got a pictu job friends
family and health and when he said that
I immediately had a knee-jerk reaction I
was like in my mind that's not true
that's not true it can't be true then I
started thinking about it and I realized
yeah he's right now the interesting
thing is we have the ability to
circumvent this a little bit because we
work together so while we don't have a
lot of other friends I mean we have some
friends but I think it's clear that
we've chosen
family and job with just a few friends
and we don't exercise
yeah there's we were talking about this
is no exercise and we do some active
things but there's no like commitment to
health right and beyond our friendship
and the few other friendships that we
have that are not regular like see
people on a regular basis its job and
family but it's interesting that you're
right we've kind of gamed the system
because we've we work together and we
are friends and here's how we are we
really friends or coworkers know we're
for that's that's the question here but
no listen we can totally gain this
system all for if we get those
treadmills that juice you run on those
little elliptical machines that you do
while you're at your stand-up desk right
that will never happen
I think what you need to think it is but
we need to make it an exercise channel
we need to we need to totally change our
brand to just be like we're exercise
we're personal trainers well we could do
an exercise channel that's the only way
to make it work but just one of the
people that we're training our friends
that we're making in real life and
they're like in the room that's how we
do it that's how we gain the system
completely mm-hmm well we could just get
one of those little ellipticals I'm not
talking about that like the big
elliptical that way I'm talking about
this little thing that little stair step
thing that wise we're at our stand-up
desk but like if that's the noise you're
gonna be making the entire time then
you're gonna lose the friendship ask
they're only gonna be making that noise
the first three months and somebody
adjusted we can adjust this or we could
just you know come to grips with the
fact that that's how it is and we're
choosing our two and we get a little bit
of friendship too and we should just be
thankful [ __ ] and try to game the
system without health though we'll die
but we'll be happy oh okay
die happy I went we didn't you know I
wonder what he said right now he's got
just job and job just job and job so
he's only put picked one yeah he doubled
down and well can't blame him
well he's saying he's a single guy you
know he can kind of get away with it
right now
so thanks Michael for coming in be sure
to tweet at Michael and let him know I'm
kind of I'm actually looking right now I
think it's tweet sauce if you go to
twitter.com slash tweet sauce huh yep
that's it
you can let him know that you listen to
this weak sauce you have a you've gained
an understanding of the man behind the
science and these two men are gonna be
here next week delivering you more
stories I want for somebody don't wanna
say stories from the road I don't know
why well that's a new podcast yeah it
sounded like it sounded good we're gonna
start that on Sunday stories from the
road
but in the meantime we hope you enjoyed
this ear biscuit with a little bit of
Vsauce on it think about that a little
bit of that green Vsauce on your ear
biscuit mental picture eat it
[Music]
[Music]